our speaker tonight was a lieutenant
with the 4th Infantry Division in
Vietnam which was one of the reasons for
Forrest Gump
that's probably his most famous work but
he also was a very serious historian
he's also written a storm in Flanders
better times than these as Summers died
in enshrouds of glory his latest book
1940 1942
the time that tried men's souls looks at
an interesting period in American
history when we just had entered the war
for Atlantians 1942 was a really bleak
time we as a community were very
flattered to have a warship the USS
Atlanta light cruiser it was christened
by Margaret Mitchell sent out into the
Pacific was guarding the landing at
Guadalcanal was struck by enemy fire as
well as friendly fire lost over a
hundred and seventy-nine men mostly from
Georgia was ordered to be destroyed
because it was listing and sinking and
the men from the Atlanta many of our
families here their descendents refused
to leave their ship without striking
their flag and taking their Bell anybody
that wants to see the Bell from the USS
Atlanta it's in our storage area give me
a call I'll let you see it but it the
Atlanta story in 1942 I think is a real
reflection of the determination of the
people of Atlanta this is a city that
can do anything if it puts its mind to
it the citizens of Atlanta were so
furious that their warship was
christened by Margaret Mitchell sent out
to the Pacific and almost immediately
sunk that they passed hat and raised
over 60 million dollars in 1943 to build
another USS Atlanta and two destroyers
to keep that one safe and
and Margaret Mitchell rechristened the
next USS Atlanta and anybody want to see
the shards of the christening bottle
give me a call because we have them all
it's now my pleasure to introduce
Winston groom who will talk about other
memorable events in 1942 Winston
[Applause]
I don't thank you very much I have to
tell you that I've been doing a little
traveling lately and I woke up very
early this morning in my hotel room and
I knew I was in Atlanta but I decided I
was going to go and get a ginger ale or
a sprite out of the minibar in my room
then I was forcible and very forcibly
reminded I was in Atlanta because there
wasn't anything in and many more but
Coca Cola's somebody took my notes
and normally my wife likes to have me
travel with these real nice fancy
leather binders that these notes go in
but I've been up in the mountains and I
place up there and all I could find was
a legal pad to write on and I just
noticed that I had scribbled on the
front page the dedication to my next
book and to my little seven-year-old
daughter Caroline I'm not gonna groom so
I didn't want to lose that I reckon I
could wing it here you know this is a
subject that's so broad and what I wrote
in 1942 the book is really an overview
of the war and the reason that I wrote
the book people ask me this all the time
well why did you take a 1942 as a
subject and it was because right after
September 11th 19 2001 I was just as
frustrated and angry as anybody else and
I was thinking well we know what can I
do I figured I was too old to go back in
the army so I thought well now what can
I write that might inspire Americans to
see what their country can and will do
when it gets attacked that way and it
suddenly occurred to me that there were
very eerie parallels between and the
Pearl Harbor attack in 1941 and the
September 11th attack I mean you had
religious fanatics you had and in the
case of Japan a nation that had been in
the asite airplane attacks and in fact
that was what was originally proposed by
Admiral Yamamoto for Pearl Harbor
because he believed that if he brought
his carriers within striking distance of
Pearl Harbor they would be subject to
being sunk so his notion was originally
before his people got to him and
explained why not to have his carrier
and carriers launch their plane 600
miles out where no American force could
get him and then bombed Pearl Harbor and
they then couldn't have enough fuel to
get back to the carriers which would
have taken off anyway and they would be
left to crash in the ocean but wiser
heads prevailed at least for his side
and they didn't do that and it wasn't
necessary anyway because they called us
with their pants down but it occurred to
me that the attack on Pearl Harbor was
certainly the kind of attack that riles
up Americans I mean you have to
understand that in within a week or or
less than that we were right up to the
time of Pearl Harbor the Gallup polls
showed that more than 70 percent of
Americans were not for getting into
World War two after Pearl Harbor a
hundred percent were except perhaps for
a few cranks you know as I said it this
is a big book it's a big overview survey
counter book and if I try to get deeply
into any subject we're gonna be here for
several days without a lunch break so
let me just kind of cruise over it as
best I can and I'll tell you this is the
first time I have spoken to an audience
and not only though I've spoke at all in
Co sizes but not about this book what I
mostly been doing is why it's talking to
television shows and radio shows where
you do a sound byte so forgive me if I
stumble a little but I'm gonna try to
get you out of here on time
let's just think the causes of World War
two in general what you had prior to the
war was a disgruntled Germany in a
disgruntled Japan both of which
countries fell into the hands of
militarist and the u.s. as I said wanted
no part of this
neither did Great Britain neither did
France and so the Western powers allowed
these people to rise up and we have seen
what a horror that that war was I mean
that the Second World War was the
seminal event of the 20th century and
when I started thinking about it I
thought in reading about it I thought
well you know 1942 was the seminal event
of the Second World War it began in a
cataract of defeats for the first six
months of that year we meaning the
Allies which at that point consisted of
the United States and Great Britain and
Russia and were you know in a horrible
horrible fix the second half of 1942
ended with a smell of victory and I
think it was Churchill was Churchill who
said this is not the end and it's not
even that the beginning of the end it's
the end of the beginning
Roosevelt said in 1942 that the axis new
meaning Germany Japan and in Italy that
if they did not win the war in 1942 they
would lose everything and he was
absolutely right
in 1942 was the most dangerous year of
the war because it was the only year of
the war in which the Allies were in any
serious danger of
losing it if you look at the beginnings
of America's involvement following Pearl
Harbor all of the the Far East was lost
to Japan the Germans were banging on the
gates of Moscow and Stalingrad and
Leningrad and in the Middle East the
German armies had pushed the British
armies all the way back to Egypt and
were threatening to push right through
Egypt to the oil-rich Middle East these
would have been calamities that they
didn't happen as a testimony to the
bravery of a lot of a lot of people on
whether they're American British Russian
and so on a lot of people don't realize
it but very soon after we entered the
war United States shipping which went
from the oil fields of Texas to just
merchant shipping all up and down the
coast of America were being slaughtered
by German submarines right off the coast
in plain view of people who were
sunbathing on the beach
I believe the figure is 350 tankers and
Russian ships were sunk within view of
Norfolk of Miami or New Orleans or well
not noise it's up the river but you know
in all along the coast and of course
this horrible debt Trias would wash up
on shore because if an oil tanker blew
up it was a dreadful experience I kept a
little piece I ripped out of my ripped
out of one of my books but I get them
for free
and by merchant seamen of the day and he
says we was carrying 50,000 pounds of
Oklahoma crude and 50,000 of high test
gasoline it sure gives you a funny
feeling I thought we'd get it any man
any minute man those nights are killers
you sleep with your clothes on
and I don't exactly mean sleep so
somebody beats on your door and it turns
out it's only the watch and you settle
down and try to light a cigarette if
your hand don't shake too much not that
you're scared of course oh no after the
Pearl Harbor attack which I'm sure you
all remember MIDI practically all of the
capital ships in the Pacific Fleet at
the bottom of Pearl Harbor and the
Japanese immediately attacked Wake
Island and the Philippines and of course
in Asia its Singapore Hong Kong and the
rest of Southeast Asia and they
conquered just about all of it at that
point the conquered all of it we lost a
hundred and twenty-five thousand man
army of General MacArthur at in in the
Philippines which is a main battle army
battle force over there and by Oh
three months later the Japanese were
actually bombing Australia and many
families in Australia northern Australia
were moving there their folks south it
was not known whether they intended to
invade it or not but there's certainly
speculation that they did when the
Japanese conquered the Philippines they
perpetrated something that in the annals
of military warfare modern military
warfare I'm not talking about what the
Carthaginians might have done
but we're talking about modern war what
we would call civilized war if there is
such a thing which there probably isn't
they perpetrated indeed that it's come
to be known as the bat and death march
where they took I believe it's about
sixty-five or seventy thousand American
soldiers when they conquered betaine who
were exhausted they were out of food
they were out of water they hadn't had
to sleep in a long time and a superior
army took them and when they were
supposed to be taken care of with
prisoners they marched them
approximately 70 miles to death camps
and they killed thousands and thousands
of them along the way in the most brutal
manner possible I have a you know people
say that the British were the great
poets of war and indeed in World War one
that was true and you had some of the
finest poetry coming out of that
conflict that's ever been written but
there were American poets and here's one
his name is Richard Henry Lee and he
died in one of these concentration camps
in the Philippines but before he died he
wrote poetry and he would keep it in a
little hole in the ground where an owl
lived in his death camp and but he
wrapped it up he found some kind of
cellophane or whatever the passes for
the things that she put on your freezer
bag today but kept the moisture off of
it and it was discovered after the war
and published in a little book and I
think it's some of the finest sports
were in the world with his what he had
to say about marching on that death
march when all of his friends were
dropping around him or being banned
headed to death or having their heads
chopped off a shot or just dying of
thirst or whatever is he told it the
prisoners March the death of a friend
so you are dead the easy words contain
no sense of loss no sorrow no despair
the hunger thirst fatigue combined to
drain all feeling from our hearts the
endless glare the brutal heat and this
the sighs demand
I cannot mourn you now I lift my load
the suffering column moves I leave
behind only another corpse beside the
road now when you consider this was a
man who was actually in the middle of it
when he wrote it I think that's
something it's one thing to reflect on
it years later but we'll hear from from
lieutenant Lee a few times later a lot
has been written about the homefront in
World War two but I don't know how many
people I certainly don't remember I was
born in 1943 a year after that and was
just a little kid and the war was long
over but the way that this country
responded was absolutely astounding we
had in this country at the beginning of
World War two 20% of our industry was
devoted to war perd war products by the
end of 1942 80% was you can you imagine
a country where 80% of all the industry
is supporting the war that they're
making you know what they used to make
tote hangers now they're making the
cannons women of course began to enter
the workforce for the very first time
and they went to places that they'd
never heard of before I mean women from
Appalachia were going to Pittsburgh to
working in steel mills gasoline was
rationed at five I believe yes I think
I'm right here five
gallons a week which is not really
enough to get you in the store if you'd
rather learn those big SUVs aluminum was
given a big premium so they had drives
for that and the ladies would take all
their aluminum pots and pans and turn
them in at various centers only to learn
after they've been told that the
aluminum was to be used to make aircraft
if that wasn't the right kind of
aluminum and so the aluminum people
bought up the pots and pans and melted
it down and sold it back to the ladies
there was a place it's really
astonishing called Willow Run it's up by
Detroit run by the automobile industry
but they had gotten into the aircraft
industry as well it was one of the most
enormous war production plants in in the
world and may have been the most
enormous it was some square miles all
undercover employed 50,000 people and
they intended to turn out a thousand
planes a month and they they barely
managed to turn out a hundred but one of
the interesting things about that to me
was that they employed a small army of
midgets which they had collected from
circuses and from Hollywood who could
get inside the finished fuselages of the
plane where nobody else could get and
finish him off and then on the home
front there were all that went when the
war quick schemes is what I call them
invariably there was the death ray which
had been around since World War one and
one fellow actually persuaded a bunch of
army generals to go up to their Aberdeen
Proving Ground in Maryland so he could
demonstrate his death right and he set
it all up and he pointed to herd of
sheep on a hillside said he's gonna kill
him with the death right so he turned on
the death
riding the Sheep were unaffected and he
packed up his death ray and went back to
the drawing boards but there were any
number of these interesting things that
there was a man who he had the great
idea of using bats for the American
military effort and what he thought was
that since Tokyo in those days was
basically a city of paper in would they
use paper to side the houses with if you
could put it incendiary device on a bat
and then turn them loose somehow with
Tokyo they'd hang up in the eaves and
then the insanity device would go off
and it's it set tokyo on fire but as it
turned out the best well that they went
down to Mammoth Cave in California and
he captured about a thousand bats in a
net and they sent him up to Harvard and
but it turned out that the incinerator
device was too heavy for the bat to
carry and so they plummeted to the
ground then the yacht the I did it to
get these big Central America bats which
I don't know whether they're fruit bats
or whatever they are but they're big
bats
so they captured a bunch of them and
they sent them up to to Harvard but it
turned out that it was mating season for
the bats and the result after many
millions of dollars were expended on
this that the bat experiment did not
work but the most incredible of all was
what I call the dog army there was a
Swiss man from Santa Fe who he had a
good spiel because he persuaded the
United States Army and the Marine Corps
to get behind him in this he calculated
that there were some 16 million dogs in
America he also calculated that in order
to retake the Pacific Islands which the
Japanese had by then fortified he
remember all the pictures of the landing
craft coming in and
the ramp comes down and the Marines come
out with guns and they all get shot down
this guy had an idea that when the
landing craft came in and landed on the
beach and the ramp came down you've had
thousands of vicious dogs that went out
and they would attack the the Japanese
and disrupt their machine guns and
mortars and whatever they had there well
the army bought it and so they set up
and I've seen pictures of the amount of
fact that pictures in my book of this
they set up an operation on a place of
all names cat island they owned in
Mississippi sound across from Pass
Christian where Steve Ambrose used to
live and it's still out there
and they employ I don't know how many
people they got thousands of dogs they
had a outcry or requests for all the
Americans to send your dog off to war
and tens of thousands did the head to
collection points all over the country
these dogs were shipped down the cat
alley and you can see in the photographs
these rows of kennels and some private
soldiers standing outside a each one
with a dog on a leash like that but one
of the major problems was what to do
about training these dogs if you don't
get vicious dogs to just attack Japanese
I mean what you don't
and so that somebody came up with the
notion of abusing Japanese prisoners as
bait but it turned out there weren't any
Japanese prisoners because they didn't
take prisoners they all got killed so
the next notion was well let's use the
nisi which were the not American
citizens they were Japanese who lived
here and some of them when these these
internment camps and even the army said
no he said this is very bad PR so they
got a bunch of I say a bunch of they got
a couple of companies of Japanese
soldiers who were fighting for the
Americans this was beginning of the DC
regiments that were up in Wisconsin and
they asked him to volunteer for a very
dangerous mission and they sent him down
to Cat Island and and they dressed him
up in these big old padded suits and he
put hockey gloves on them you know like
you see with the police duties police
dogs and he started trying to teach the
dogs to go after Japanese and the poor
Japanese got all bitten up I mean they
had you know catcher's mitt face masks
on everything but as it turned out the
and in the general of this whole thing
came down from the Pentagon and awarded
them all
I think the Bronze Star but as it turned
out the dogs were worthless because it
was discovered that artillery would
drive the dogs completely insane they
were no good and others were just docile
so there went to dog army now there was
another event that came along fairly
early in April of 1942 called the
Doolittle raid and that's one of the
bravest things I have ever encountered
if when you look in the annals of
warfare because Jimmy Doolittle was at
old reach ready from World War one he's
an old man by there his forties but he
was asked to lead a raid on Tokyo from
aircraft carriers she essentially
partially avenged Pearl Harbor in raise
morale at home he agreed to do this
the problem was we'll have what kind of
planes were gonna do it a fighter plane
is not going to do it because they can't
do anything tell you you had to have a
bomber but the aircraft cares America
had weren't designed for bombers and so
the only bombers they could use was army
bombers they finally settled on a b25 to
jest dinner which is quite good by the
way that anyway he he organized this
raid and he even gave it to his guys who
did not know they were volunteers too
and they were blind volunteer didn't
know where they were going they might
have had a suspicion but he told them
you got about a 50-50 chance coming back
not one man walked out of that and they
and they had to leave much earlier than
they thought
from the aircraft carriers because they
had been spotted by a Japanese patrol
boat they bomb Tokyo and the only way
they could get out of it alive they
couldn't get back to the carry as they
had to go land in China but because they
left early they landed in them well in
landing in the middle of the night they
all ran a gas had to bail out and every
one of them got back alive except for
three who were shot in the back of the
head
by the Japanese in an execution in the
meantime in that spring the Germans were
seriously onto the Russians and it was a
great doubt if that was going to come to
any good in the the Germans outside of
Moscow found the home of Leo Tolstoy the
great novelist and burned all of his
manuscripts and then for good measure
they found the home of the composer
Tchaikovsky thank you sir
mr. Tchaikovsky had all his music burned
a month after the D little raid there
was a great battle in the Coral Sea
which is the first battle ship the ship
or aircraft carrier aircraft carrier
between the Americans and Japanese it
was also just historically the first
battle in history between ships were
neither that no ship saw the other ship
it was all aircraft and and there are
conflicting views on it tactically
America probably lost that battle
because we lost the de Lexington which
is a great aircraft carrier and the
Yorktown was so badly damaged that
nobody thought she could be put back
together within several months but
several months we didn't have because
the following month came a Battle of
Midway and the Yorktown limped back to
Pearl Harbor and Admiral Nimitz himself
went down and said you say it's can take
two months it's going to take two days
it has to because we were reading the
Japanese mail and we knew that they were
planning an operation a big operation
against Midway Island which was our
farthest outposts in the eastern Pacific
where we could monitor what the Japanese
were doing well they did it two days
they put your town back together and she
went out with and two other carriers and
it was numerically almost sending these
a fleet to slaughter because we had
three carriers
the Japanese had eight they had eleven
battleships we had none they were in the
ocean at the bottom of it but only four
Japanese carriers came to Midway and
through an amount of guts in luck we
managed to sink all four of those
carriers again there was great heroism
there I mean you had whole torpedo
squadrons of you know two six or 12
planes getting shot down shot right out
of the sky but without inflicting any
damage trying to get into the Japanese
fleet but then then the dive bombers
came in and the sacrifice of those
torpedo planes in bringing the and the
Japanese fighters the zeroes out of the
air and down on to the deck on in the
sea where they couldn't get back up in
town to get the dioramas that allowed us
to win the Battle of Midway and we sunk
the main Japanese battle fleet there and
then and they were never a force again
against us that wasn't long after that
that the Americans realized that they
had to do something about a little
island called Guadalcanal which is in
the Solomons Shan and it's up about a
thousand miles northeast of Australia
and the Japanese were building an
airbase there if they had completed it
in first it would planes they could
interdict our main supply line with
Australia and that's where we were and
building up a force to try to retake the
Pacific so the authorities ordered the
1st Marine Division to go there they
were eighteen thousand Marines
reinforced marine division the old
school Marines and take while the canal
and hold it and build an airfield
well they got there and luckily they
they didn't encounter very much
resistance because all the Japanese on
Guadalcanal were construction people a
most of them were manned and the rest of
them ran off but that didn't last very
long because that very night there was
something called the Battle of Cebu
Island which and was one of six
horrendous naval fights between the
Japanese and US and basically it was
their defensive fight our offense at
fight but we lost I believe for cruises
that that evening and they're all at the
bottom of something called iron bottom
sound' which is named for the number of
ships that are sunk there they're there
today the the battles on Guadalcanal
were some of the fiercest that occurred
in the entire war the Marines were there
for six months and you know it was
learned in World War one you can't keep
a man on the frontline for more than
four days he had to rotate him back well
there wasn't any back in Guadalcanal and
the Japanese were bombing night and day
they were sending battleships down and
destroying the airbase the Marines
didn't even have enough to eat they had
to eat leftover Japanese rice but at
least the Japanese left Sachi with it
they were starving to death they were
undergoing every kind of medical ailment
that you can imagine from a tropical
jungle especially malaria and dysentery
which are completely disabled if I
remember right the you had to be in
those days under order have a
temperature of 103 degrees before you
can even go to sick bay but and we we
battle all those elements there at
Guadalcanal and we prevailed after six
months I think 50,000 Japanese would
kill there and if you include the Navy
casualties which were
terrible probably 10,000 Americans but
at the end of it we held while the canal
and that according to just about every
Japanese Admiral in general was the low
point in their war they believe that
that was the turnaround point when they
lost Guadalcanal because that's the
first time we'd ever fought Japanese and
at the same time a Japanese were being
ejected from Guadalcanal there was a big
fight going on in New Guinea which is
the biggest island in the world second
biggest island I think after Greenland
and that was when MacArthur's troops got
in and these were National Guard troops
and they had a similar situation where
the Japanese were trying to get a an arm
in for a better grab on Australia they
were ejected at great cost in the
European campaigns for the Western
campaigns in October of 1942 a battle
was fought by the British at el-alamein
and which the British general Montgomery
managed to defeat the British general
Rommel and drive him back out of Egypt
across Libyan back toward Tunisia at the
same time and the Americans landed in
North Africa at Morocco and Algeria and
it was successful landing all that we
had defend ourselves against the French
who were against us at that point the
Vichy French it was controlled by the
Germans but that was brought under
control fairly quickly
it was rough going in in in that part of
the world and one of the reasons was
nobody understood the terrain or the
weather for instance
this is a you know November December
January in North Africa but the War
Department for some reason believed that
this was Africa and so they provided our
troops would essentially tropical
clothing because it was Africa well
North Africa is roughly the same
latitude as Washington DC so the guys
were freezing and in the mud and so on
but we again prevailed in that the
Philippines meanwhile the Americans in
the Philippines were undergoing an
ordeal of astonishing proportions in
these basically death camps that the
Japanese kept for them they were
starving because they had every medical
problem that you're going to find in the
tropics there was no medicine for them
they were dying out like flies and it
was a it was a bad situation but still
by the end of 1942 hard fought as it was
and this is the reason I thought it
would be an instructive idea for a book
by the end of 1942 the Axis powers never
gained one more mile aground not one the
rest of the three years of war horrible
as it was was driving him back to where
they came from which we did and thank
you very much
[Applause]
as I said I was only used to doing sound
bites and didn't know how long this talk
was going to be because I just had some
notes I I've been skipping through it
and I want to get you all out of here
before the Roosters started to crow or
the cows come home so we've got about 15
minutes for questions and I'm open to
any any question just about any question
anybody have a question do I have to ask
myself a question I can answer it if I
do well you have a question did you
women tell you what you're supposed to
go back there and talking to that sense
of microphone that thing up there you
talked about parallels at the beginning
of the book and you've mentioned it
tonight between 40 to 1942 and what
happened in 9/11 can you give us some of
your thoughts about our level of
preparedness compared to 1942 level of
are the parallels that you see well I
think preparedness we were totally
unprepared for the Second World War we
were getting prepared for it but that
wasn't anywhere near being prepared but
I think and what I get asked a lot is
what about the notions of patriotism in
America in say 1942 is compared with now
and it's been my observation that
following the attack on Pearl Harbor
Americans were was solid they were
solidified against the the Axis powers
and they remain that way until the end
of the war and then they started their
political bickering again today after
September the 11th and the terrorist
attack in New York in Washington the
country was solidified for six months or
a year
when we didn't get attacked again that
political bickering started I'm not sure
that's very healthy but I do think that
there you can you can make those
comparisons and and you know make what
you want of them yes Gate Bridge
California is something that sounded me
when uh I stumbled upon it I don't know
if you're familiar with it but there's a
gun emplacement there built a tunnel
built right into the mountains seaward
and this is an emplacement for the
16-inch guns from our battleships that
according to the the plaque was built
because we were fearful of an invasion
so this would be basically a Lance
land-based
battleship 16-inch gun emplacement but
the gun was never put there because of
the change in the tide of events that
you started to describe it is wondering
if you had any information on that in
your research I don't have any
information on that but I can tell you
this that the Californians were
desperately afraid at least for the
first year there in 42 that invasion as
a matter of fact a Japanese submarine
surfaced off of Santa Barbara about two
months after Pearl Harbor and begins
shelling it there were some oil
facilities there and it frightened the
daylights out of the people in Santa
Barbara but it didn't bother the people
very much on the East Coast because they
were watching their tankers and
freighters being blown up in front of
their very eyes but not well you know
they there were all sorts of nervous
worries about a Japanese invasion they
were been ridiculous and Japan could
they could hurt us I don't think it
invaders and occupies were too big well
these were these were were concerns I
mean if somebody was serious enough to
build a tunnel and a gun emplacement so
there was apparently enough concern
about that the second question I had
really had to do with the the
destruction of the Pacific Fleet
what are the various theories that you
you run across over to comment on them
as to why the aircraft carriers we're
not import and why the entire fleet was
not destroyed
well the aircraft goes where it won't at
Pearl Harbor at Pearl Harbor yeah well
there were three three aircraft carriers
in the Pacific at that point one I
believe Saratoga was in Seattle or
somewhere being undergoing repairs and
renovation and he had enterprise and I
believe Hornet were out in the Pacific
the enterprise wasn't at Pearl Harbor
because it had been sent to deliver
aircraft to Wake Island and so it was on
the way back and Hornet I believe had
been sent to watch Japanese activities
down in the Marshall Islands which
wasn't very far away so I know that that
the Roosevelt conspiracy people want to
say well he got aircraft carriers out
let I fleet be sunk I don't I don't
believe that I don't think you one of
them but that's been an argument I mean
that they've been so many books come out
that say Roosevelt president Roosevelt
knew about the attack coming to Pearl
Harbor and you know my I mean I just
think to me simple logic tells you what
Roosevelt had been an assistant
secretary of the Navy in World War one
he loved the Navy he was the Navy's best
friend as the president and even if you
want to take a what-if supposition that
he knew about the coming attack why on
earth would he let the Japanese sink his
entire Pacific Fleet and kill all those
sailors why wouldn't he say should don't
tell anybody about it we know they're
coming there you guys get ready and
you'll meet them and sink their ships
and kill their sailors I'll be just
that's just logic I don't know who's my
logic Alabama thank you
what level of communication was there in
1942 between Germany and Japan and
coordinating and court and coordinating
their aggression accordingly
coordinating their aggression that's a
very good question here that question
all right the level of communication
between Germany and Japan in
coordinating their aggression during
endlessly during the year 1942 even 1941
it was strange the Japanese had an
ambassador in Germany who was treated
almost like a spy but he could glean
information but the Germans were as
surprised as anybody including the
Americans when the Japanese attacked
Pearl Harbor they told no one
I think the Germans had a rough idea
that there was not a lot of coordination
between these powers even though they
both were adjoining the access pact but
I think that there I know that I've seen
documents that have shown a desire by
the Germans to drive through Egypt get
to the Middle East at the same time
Japan was going to drive through India
and meet up with the Germans and that
would have put us in a in a fix that put
the Allies in a big fix because it'd be
hard to dislodge them from that kind of
thing
President President Roosevelt wanted to
direct all our efforts in in support of
Great Britain what was it two or three
days after Pearl Harbor the Germans
declared war on us if that hadn't
happened two things would we have been
able to get a declaration in this
country against the Germans and the
Italians and if we had would we still
have been able to concentrate our
efforts in the European theater
we did early in the war well that's one
of the best questions I've been asked
about this book and all the two or three
months I talked about it did everybody
hear it in the back and several days
after Pearl Harbor the Germans and the
Italians declared war on us we never
declared war on them until after they
had done it to us and this gentleman's
question is well if Germany hadn't
declared war on us and and in Italy
could we have gotten a declaration of
war against them through the Congress
and nobody will know that precisely but
I think it would have it may have gone
it's just I'm making a supposition but
they've been a lot of fighting about it
there would been all sorts of hollering
and yelling because nobody wanted to go
and fight a European war again we'd
already fought one European war and we
hadn't been attacked well we've been
sort of attacked by Germany with some of
these submarines but nothing like what
happened at Pearl Harbor so that again
is a is a what if I kind of like what if
questions and I think that you can only
surmise that yeah sue will later we'd
had gotten into it with Germany and in
Italy but it might have taken a big
political fight to do it Japanese
invasion of the Aleutians did you think
about the atmosphere in Britain in 1942
well the the the first question that I
mentioned anything about the Japanese
invasion of the Aleutian Islands I sure
did and it's been a whole long time was
it because there wasn't a lot to it I
mean it as far as the Japanese did hold
one of our Lucian Islands which is part
of the chain in Alaska and and we
ultimately kicked them out the second
part of the question was that I talked
about or will I talk about what the
atmosphere was and in Great Britain
19:42 well it was I believe a great
relief because they had essentially won
the Battle of Britain which was an air
war in 1941 so they weren't getting
bombed you know daily and it is horrible
tens of thousands of death they've been
undergoing in 1941 40 and 41 but they
also had a great sense of relief because
they knew America was in the war against
Germany and because they they were
standing alone alongside Russia and that
was it all these other countries when
you call it a world war you know if you
take all the South American countries in
the Central American countries and a
little townie countries you never even
heard of they didn't get into it till
nineteen forty four forty five until
they saw which way the wind was going to
blow so it was really the three powers
were America Great Britain and Russia
against Germany Italy and Japan that she
was doing the fight in 1942 just mr.
Graham two questions first of all mr.
groom is my father
I'm sorry Winston right first question
is obviously 1942 is a watershed year in
your opinion what were the the biggest
strategic blunders that the Axis powers
made in 42 that's the first question and
the second question is you hear so
little about what really happened on the
Russian front and there's a lot stuff
been written about it but you don't give
that much information on it and I
understand that 80% of the German
casualties in the world in world war ii
or on the Russian front can you comment
a little bit about how important was to
keep Russia in the fight well let's take
the second question first it was vital
to keep Russia in the fight because the
Germans had if I'm not mistaken three or
four million troops over there and these
could have been turn loose against any
effort that the Allies had including the
effort on d-day so we were doing
everything we could sending all sorts of
material that could have been used by
our troops in the Pacific and that's
where we were fighting for most of war
of 1942
we were sending that to Russia or to
Great Britain and I forgot your first
question no strategic blunders by the
axis in 42 where were great many of them
mean the first one began in 1941 with
the Japanese attacked us at Pearl Harbor
if they hadn't if they hadn't I
optimally it we would have been drawn
into the war but maybe later
and again that's that's what is but well
and the the fact that Hitler refused to
supply Rommel in the North African
deserts led to his destruction of his
army and and that was a big army that
was the the their primary North African
force that caused the ultimately the
whole fall of North Africa if he could
have held if Roman could have held the
British in in Egypt or even Libya for
that matter then it would have taken
months if not years to dislodge them but
he couldn't so that that wound him up
those are just two that I think there
was saboteurs led to its pilot read in
Florida and I believe southern New
Jersey well hell is Long Island I used
to live there I used to live in East
Hampton is if there's an Amagansett
which is a very expensive place now was
any significant sabotage and this cut
they're doing 40 to it during the war
well that's a good question too that the
Germans tried some sabotage they had a
couple of submarines take I believe it
was a six-man team and they landed one
out in the Hamptons on the beach they
were clowns the one was an American well
he'd been born a German but he raised in
America and immediately they they
somehow got away from the Coast Guard
and they founded uniforms buried and
they went into New York where the
the leader of the team who was the
German born American turned everybody
else in because he figured that they
will come get hung his spies they didn't
they got electrocuted under orders of
President Roosevelt in a military
tribunal and the same thing happened
with the ones who landed down in Ponte
Vedra which is also another fancy place
they got policed up too but that